i was just thinking right now there's
this image i think about this often
one of my favorite sort of funny images
that comes to mind
sometimes is in boogie nights when your
character is trying a new look
oh yeah you have the yeah the the wig
and this i forget what the what it
and you look you're alone at a party and
you're despondent
wearing that outfit and it's it's just
such a great
there's so much comedy in that moment
and sadness
it's at the same time that moment in
fact was
so pta paul thomas anderson who directed
that
so i get in the get up i'm sitting there
and he comes over and he says okay now
in this moment i just want
i just want nothing i just want nothing
nothing happening
i was like nothing i don't know okay
so we shoot it get cut he comes over he
goes you were kind of
doing nothing i just want nothing
like nothing i'm like nothing's like
yeah just just give me nothing
so i'm sitting there trying to figure
out this it was like a japanese koan you
know i'm like
trying to figure out what he means yeah
and he comes back he goes okay got it
thanks so much so while you were trying
to figure out his direction
he got with you yeah he rolled on the
camera you know that scene i'm talking
about andy it's just it's
i i there's so much i love that movie
but there's this
uh you're you sitting there
totally despondent uh and i feel like
yeah
i've been there many times in my life
i've been wearing that wig i've probably
been wearing another wig or another
costume
but i've been totally like my soul has
left my body yeah
and and it was such a brilliant way for
him to
to get at that because the direction was
baffling yeah and i think when i look at
it that's the look on it on my
there's just nothing in there just like
some empty vessel
like why am i in this movie why did i
let
him talk me into this